yes the social networking feature of the
dunder mifflin infiniti website
was infiltrated by sexual predators i
don't understand why our website needs
to have social networking at all yeah i
actually have to agree with dwight on
that one it's all about creating a
one-stop
consumer experience all right you're
chatting with your friends
you're talking about the latest music
about the election
all of it is happening in our virtual
paper store
and then an older gentleman asks you
boxers or briefs i don't get the big
fuss here i like the site
if i had created a website with this
many problems i'd kill myself
do you have a question kelly yeah i have
a lot of questions number one how dare
you
danny if we're still single in five
years
and we haven't found anybody can we make
a pact
that we will kill each other yeah
absolutely a lot of angry customers out
there this puts us at threat level
midnight
accounting you are on customer service
duty today that's really not our job
midnight
oscar don't worry kelly will be training
you first
kelly's training us this day
is bananas b-a-n-a-n-a-s this day
is bananas b-a-n-a
i don't have a headache i'm just
preparing
you're at the golden globes okay you
just tripped
and fell on the red carpet no yes the
whole world is watching your face down
your dress is over your head toby
mcguire is laughing at you the whole
world is watching what are you gonna do
you're gonna sit there and cry you're
gonna push yourself up and show them a
best actress in a mini series or motion
picture made for television nominee
mindy lahiri is made of what are you
gonna do
nice that was great did i win no you
lost to stocker channing
hey kelly what's up nothing
oh except oh my god jim last night ryan
and i
totally finally hooked up it was awesome
that's great
i'm really happy for it i know it was so
funny because we were at this bar with
his friends and i was sitting next to
him the whole night
and he wasn't making a move so in my
head i was like ryan what's taking you
so long
and then he kissed me and i didn't know
what to say so i said
ryan what took you so long i mean he
just said it to him can you believe that
wow oh my god jim is that embarrassing
i'm embarrassed
no don't be no thank god because i was
nervous jim you will not
believe i was so nervous but now now i
have a boyfriend
all right i hooked up with her on
february 13th
i don't know what he's thinking but i
would just be so psyched if we just
dated forever
no i take it slow because it seems like
a lot of the time things like that need
soda cool
hey so do you want to do something
tonight or oh no not while i'm
here i mean i know that's valentine's
day or whatever but there's totally no
pressure
at all of any kind whatsoever so i can't
tonight i have plans with my friends
okay um that's cool okay completely
understand cool
okay
why are you naked why are you in the
girls it's co-ed
here here fine take my towel that is so
much worse don't drop it on the floor
your genitals what was on that
pick it up it's my favorite towel oh
mindy i think we have a little problem
[Music]
sorry sorry sorry i'm sorry why did you
wear a watch to a steering wheel this is
a 35
watch i'm not going to leave it in the
locker room oh god just turn just turn
oh my god oh my god
don't use me for leverage nothing this
is nothing
oh you okay
so how are you awesome
i am dating a lot of guys good a lot
black guys mostly kelly what
wait how do you touch just one of these
buttons at a time
i don't know did you even try
if the kid wants to set mine up i'll let
him i can't see half the things
it's too little use the phone
i want you to tell me that you care
about me that is what i want
kelly i'm your boss now okay you can't
keep talking to me like i'm your
boyfriend
oh big strong man fancy new whatever
i don't think you ever cared about me i
never cared about you six months ago
karen filippelli sent me an email
asked me out i said no because i was
committed to our relationship
well i hope you're still committed
because i'm pregnant
and guess what buddy i am keeping it
okay
okay do you feel prepared to help me
raise a baby
i can't talk about this right now okay
after work we'll go out to dinner
we'll talk about it then okay
we have a date i think they really like
each other no they like paul simon so is
everyone else on the planet you look
amazing
i'm not even here hey god hey there's
four of us here so let's
try that let's see sorry danny was just
helping me
figure out where i should get my first
tattoo uh-oh
um you hate tattoos no i don't think so
i think i'm gonna get a tattoo as well a
little butterfly on the nape of my neck
and he would signify that i'm a free
spirit
what tattoo are you gonna get well i
think i should keep it a secret because
where i want to get it only certain
people would see it
i i don't know liz i worry that a tattoo
is a little short-sighted
yeah is your grandson really gonna
understand why you have a radiohead
lyric under your belly button
i can't understand ready to head now do
you wanna
tap something like that next movie moves
to the top of the queue so number five
becomes number four number six becomes
number five
number three becomes number two etc etc
and let's just say that i just sent back
love actually which was awesome
and they sent me uptown girls which is
also awesome but guess what
now i want to see love actually again
but it's at the bottom of the queue oh
no what do i do
what i do is this i go online i go click
click click
and i change the order of the queue so i
can see love actually as soon as i want
to
it's so easy ryan do you really not know
how
netflix works i guess i forgot
you're such a dick ryan well done two
minutes 42 seconds
additionally pam you win 10 because she
said awesome 12 times
and jim you win five because she
mentioned six romantic comedies oh my
god
peter please promise me that you have
not
gratified yourself while you were
watching this oh my god
no i didn't peter can you please be more
convincing than that just don't look off
guiltily
look me in the eye and tell me you
didn't do it i didn't oh
god oh god look i know this is bad for
the whole practice
i gotta say i've never met a real
pornography actor up close and personal
kind of geeking out
i can't i need to lie on the floor can i
ask you a question
now what was with that trumpet music
that was just my next-door neighbor
practicing his
trumpet it's actually kind of beautiful
if you listen to it there was a very
spirited debate about that in the
comment section
the comment section well yeah it's a
video online
okay verified user bro bgyn says
hey i work with her i told you it was
geeking out i gave it three stars
we just want to say we are very sorry
screw you guys you're dead to me if you
say screw you one more time
where are you from i don't forget your
birthday hey
hey guys we just want to make it up to
you what can we do
i guess my only wish would be that
nothing so terrible would ever happen to
anyone else ever again
oh god okay in a way it's good that it
happened to me because at least i can
bury what kind of
cake do you want imbecile ice cream
hey there you go why is this stake way
what's with this green crud
where's my dessert oh yeah i forgot
sorry i printed out
these really funny yogi bear quotes if
you're still hungry
just read those that will definitely
take your mind off things hey guys
we're gonna party like it's my birthday
cause it is
oh my god it's my favorite kind of cake
gigantic
you're shaking are you all right just
leave me alone
i am on the third day of my cleanse diet
all i have to do
is drink maple syrup lemon juice cayenne
pepper and water for all three meals
um i just bought some bikinis online
size two
so i look amazing
hey morgan you were right this is a bad
idea
oh my god hi i was gone for like 10
seconds
i felt like forever what it felt like
forever
uh you're using like a bedroom voice i
honestly can't hear you open those
blinds and let's let the stars watch
come here you
please don't act so shocked and
disgusted it's a little offensive
take your stuff this is a big mistake
just remember that it was you that asked
me moments ago to have sex with you
so i'm gonna go and i want i want to
thank you for really really making this
a great night for everyone
watson carpet and tile one order order
reference number
zero zero nine eight three dash one two
six
eight cases bright white inkjet paid
i'm dying
processed and delivered sometimes i get
so bored i just want to scream
and then sometimes i actually do scream
i just sort of feel out what the
situation calls for
you